Oh Jim sauce brand from Iowa and I would
like to know how was dark matter first
detected it how do we detect it what
what are methods for determining Jim
dark matter when was it first detected
well astronomers began to suspect that
existed
many many years ago I think back in the
1930s because it was already recognized
that we couldn't quite understand how
stars orbit around our own galaxy and
orbit in other galaxies it seems that
there's material out there that has
gravity that we cannot detect so when
you see how many stars make up a galaxy
you can estimate how how massive they
are you calculate how much gravity they
make and it's not enough so we knew a
long time ago if something was the
matter now that became much more
definite evidence about thirty years ago
and since then we've even got more kinds
through measurements of the
gravitational forces in clusters of
galaxies and some clusters of galaxies
have enough gravitational force to bend
light from more distant galaxies and so
we see distorted images and because of
this we can determine the mass of the
galaxy of galaxies and again we find
that there are galaxies which are much
more massive than we can account for by
looking at the ordinary matter that's in
them gaseous material and stars so the
upshot is we've known for a long time
that something is strange out there we
even see in the pattern of spots in the
cosmic microwave radiation and the big
bang with radiation that those spots
can't be explained unless we imagine
that there is a lot of dark matter out
there that is much more abundant maybe
five or ten times as abundant as the
matter that we're made of so that's the
astronomical method now we are hoping
that someone will actually find a
particle of dark matter in a laboratory
one of these days and we have two ways
that this might happen one is that a
Dark Matter particle might actually
interact with a object detector that we
might build and my friends in this
business say it could happen in ten or
twenty years the other way is that maybe
we'll make a particle of dark matter in
a collision experiment as
large hadron collider and this Dark
Matter particle would disappear without
a trace and it would take
however with it some matter sorry it
would take away with it some energy and
some momentum and if this would be true
then we would say well we put stuff in
and we didn't get enough back out there
must be a Dark Matter particle that
escaped from our chamber without
noticing so we have these many ways to
try to get at the Dark Matter nature but
none of them have succeeded yet